I'm Brian Kilmeade I'm at the McCallum
I'm David Asman and this is the Fox News
rundown
Wednesday April 1st 2020 I'm Dave
Anthony Americans are waiting to get
paid most of us will soon get money from
the government as part of that two
trillion dollar economic rescue package
and the best part it is gift money
you're getting you don't have to pay any
of this back okay it is not in it's not
income it doesn't come out of next
year's refund I'm Kris foster celebrity
chef Robert Irvine says a lot of
restaurants may not survive the
coronavirus shutdowns the restaurant
industry unless we do something or
hospitality I should say if you do
something really dramatic really fast
there is not gonna be one that's hotels
that motels that anybody's do food and
alcohol and I'm Leslie Marshall I've got
the final word on the Fox News rundown
[Music]
Congress is not in session at the moment
some lawmakers are in quarantine a half
dozen of either tested positive for the
corona virus or are presumed to have it
but there's already talk of a fourth
round of stimulus for an ailing economy
sickened by all the corona related
shutdowns House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
their infrastructure needs that our
country had that directly relates to how
we are proceeding with the Colonna virus
unless some Republicans are on board
with that focused on projects like roads
and bridges President Trump tweeted on
Tuesday with interest rates at zero this
is the time for a long-awaited bill and
it should be very big and bold two
trillion dollars focused solely on jobs
and rebuilding the once great
infrastructure of our country but
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham told
Fox and Friends hold on well we need to
make sure that phase three actually
works we don't have any checks out yeah
that's the two-plus trillion dollar bill
Congress approved in the President
signed last week more than 90 percent of
Americans will be getting money cash and
or expanded unemployment assistance so
we decided to break it all down for you
starting with the direct payments so for
most people it's gonna be $1200 per
adults and then $500 for each child
under 17 Richard Rubin is a Wall Street
Journal reporter who covers tax policy
you know and then starts phasing out for
people who have individuals those with
income of 75 thousand and marry couples
with joint income of a hundred and fifty
thousand above that the payment served
to shrink and then go away and what is
the formula to get to zero so the
formula for married couple you get to
zero if you have no kids you get to zero
at about a hundred and ninety eight
thousand dollars of income and it just
sort of declines basically every $100
your income goes up you lose five
dollars of the payment for a married
couple with two kids I think that it
goes to zero and about you know from
3400 it goes down to zero at about two
hundred and eighteen thousand have
income there are a couple other groups
that don't get payments and it's
important to remember that anyone who is
a dependent
and is not a child doesn't get a payment
so imagine someone who college students
17-year old high school seniors if you
have your elderly parents living with
you and you claim them as a dependent
then you wouldn't get a separate payment
for them okay and then the other big
yeah so again there's no income limit so
even though people who live
independently on Social Security on just
a disability off their savings are
eligible for payments but not if there's
somebody else's dependent and then the
other group of people who don't have
social security numbers often that's
undocumented immigrants you know if you
don't have a social security number
you're not eligible to get a payment
what is the number they're basing all of
this on this isn't the this isn't your
gross income and it's not your net
income right what is it's adjusted it's
adjusted gross income so which you can
if you have your tax return you should
from by their 2018 or 2019 you just look
for the adjusted gross income line the
US Treasury Department is trying to get
this money out quickly
the first payments may come in a few
weeks directly deposited into Americans
bank accounts what the IRS will do is if
you have filed the 2019 tax return they
will take the information from that
about your family size about your income
and use that to generate a payment and
if you've got your bank account
information on there you know that for
the refund that you've gotten from your
2019 taxes they've got that and that's
the first group that should get payments
within the next few weeks or so because
they they're just sort of ready to go
all right
if the iris doesn't have 2019 then
they'll shift to using the 2018
information and that they don't have
bank account information that will take
longer because they'll have paper checks
so if you haven't filed 2019 and you
earned a lot less in 2019 than you did
2018 you're out of luck like you could
have you could have earned less than
2019 than 2018 and in 2018 you earned
too much to get money but in 2019 you
didn't get as much but you're out a lot
yeah so there's two things to say about
that one is you
probably can go ahead and still file
2019 if you have information ready to go
I've asked the IRS for when that cutoff
is basically when it is that they're
gonna grab the 2019 batch of returns and
then you know send out those payments
based on that or switch to 2018 so
that's that's one thing we don't know
yet is how quickly you would have to get
that in but as you know that you're
gonna be better off based on your 2019
income and you're ready to file your
return go ahead and do that even though
your return isn't due until July 15th
now if your income say was high in 2018
and above those ranges and for 2020 it
comes down to within the ranges then
you'll get the payment you just won't
get it until you file your 2020 tax
return early next year
whoa so wait a minute some people some
people could still get these checks next
year yes here's how you have to think
about it you think about the check
you're getting now as basically in
addition to next year's tax refund and
they're giving it to you now the money
that's going in the mail twelve hundred
twenty four hundred or more than that if
you have kids is that borrowing from our
refunds that we're gonna get next year
from our own tax returns or is this like
a gift from the government it is gift
money you're getting you don't have to
pay any of this back okay it is not in
it's not income it doesn't come out of
next year's refund and so it's not
taxable it's not something that we have
to pay back this is a gift
the government's giving us cash and we
take it and we go with it
yes exactly let me make one other point
on the payments can I get the question I
get a lot oh yeah and you know it's
really it's really helpful is I which is
I'm on Social Security or I'm on just
ability or I want an SSI and I don't
file tax returns can I get this and the
answer is yes except unless you're
someone else is dependent right you can
get it even if you're retired or on
disability and have no income if you go
to WWII rs gov slash coronavirus they're
starting to put up some more information
about what people in
that situation should do if you don't
because a lot of those people don't
typically file tax returns they don't
have taxable income well in addition to
all that cash most of us will soon be
getting a lot more Americans will be
getting even more money in what Senate
Democratic leader Chuck Schumer called
unemployment on steroids and this comes
after a record number of first-time
jobless claims two weeks ago 3.2 eight
million and tomorrow we'll get the
numbers from last week expected to also
be millions of people newly out of work
amid the coronavirus shutdowns what this
bill does is it does a couple of
interesting things one is it increases
the benefit so it adds a six hundred
dollar federal benefit on top of what
the states are normally do and the
second thing that is is the they've
expanded the definitions of unemployment
so I would encourage people you know
people who are self-employed independent
contractors people you know who are
normally outside of the unemployment
system because they're not in a job and
then losing it I would encourage people
again go check with their individual
states to as you're filing for benefits
to try to understand how you may be
eligible even though you normally
wouldn't think of yourself as being
eligible and so we're gonna see how that
plays out over the next few weeks and
months as people kind of get used to
this new system so the federal
government is gonna funnel this money
and through each individual state is
that how it's gonna work yeah that's how
unemployment benefits work you you apply
through your state and then you know
it's it's funded part part state and now
under this program largely federal and
but all the administration and
qualification and eligibility and all
that is done through States six hundred
dollars a week is $15 an hour and that's
on top of the money that they were
already getting from the states in many
cases for a lot of people that's more
than they earned when they were still
working that's not an issue that was an
issue that some Republican senators had
as they were debating this bill and
there's obviously some concern about
that you know the people may prefer
being on that explain
that unemployment it's going back to
work but at the moment you know there
aren't really jobs to go back to because
so much in the retail sector or in
restaurants and such has been cut or
closed temporarily and and in a lot of
parts of the country and so you know we
may see that come as an issue at some
point but you know right now that's just
the sort of a secondary concerning
really actually do in some ways the
government's goal here is it sort of
backwards when we normally think
normally you're like the you would think
the government's aim is to encourage
people to work to be productive members
society to get out there and like have
jobs right right and and we're in a sort
of bizarro world now that's not
necessarily what the government's aim is
the government's aim is to pay people to
stay at home to discourage people from
going to work at least in the short term
so that people you know so that we can
slow this friends virus so it's sort of
a we're at a very strange moment for
everything but including sort of how we
think about employment policy
unlike the checks that we talked about
earlier this money is taxable right yeah
unemployment benefits are taxable you
know in the last recession Congress came
in and I he remember how much the number
was but they sort of loose into those
rules a little bit so that some of it
was not taxable so you may see them do
that again at some point but they
haven't yet and I think the other
important distinction is that you know
is that the unemployment benefits are
really about people who experiencing
this drop and they come right now
so the first batch the checks that we
talked about those in the direct
deposits those will be mid April maybe
so the expected direct posits first ones
out within a few weeks and then for
people who need paper checks it's gonna
take a bit longer so we're talking many
sort of rough time frame may perhaps we
don't know they're gonna be in batches
it's actually you know because so much
has gone electronic the government
literally just doesn't have giant check
printing machines anymore or not nearly
as many of them as they used to and so
if you either don't have a bank account
or the IRS doesn't have your banking
information it's gonna take longer
that same IRS website I talked about
before irs.gov slash coronavirus they're
gonna they don't have it up yet but
they're going to soon have a system
where you can give the IRS your bank
account information number so that they
can get you in the batch to send out the
direct payments as opposed to having to
wait for basically like a paper check
since your last known address and how
quickly will the unemployment extra 600
bucks happen so that's gonna be
state-by-state I don't quite have a feel
for exactly how quickly they you know
states that are able to turn that around
alright well a lot of people are waiting
for a lot of money Richard Rubin tax
policy reporter Wall Street Journal
thanks so much for joining us
oh sure thanks Rafi
this is leslie marshall with your fox
news commentary coming up millions of
restaurant workers at least for now or
out of a job
with their employers shut down or slowed
down by the corona virus outbreak we
were forced make the difficult decision
to close permanently
Ryan's sudden Dorf closed his Mexican
restaurant in Seattle among the three
point three million people filing for
unemployment benefits last week a lot
were in the hospitality industry there
is some help for those businesses in the
coronavirus relief bill these
restaurants including myself can apply
for some help three to be opening up
again
chef and Food Network host Robert Irvine
says he had to close three restaurants
we last spoke a few weeks ago before the
outbreak started shutting places down we
figured we should check back in now
obviously we can't open until this whole
this whole kind of thing is over and
that that could be weeks could be months
could be who knows we're not getting the
real truth on on what it is right now so
at the end of the day it really depends
on the government I mean the restaurants
are ready to open for sure I mean
they're being ready we haven't really
closed we have but we haven't we've been
there in Seoul a lot of places attempt
to go and grab and go kind of things
open but you know as much as the
community to supporting they're scared
to go our yeah I mean some places
obviously are better able to weather
this storm than others if you if you're
a pizza place or for your Chinese place
you probably already had a pretty brisk
delivery business I know a steakhouse
manager who just had to close up shop
and late 50 something people off they
can't they don't you know steak houses
aren't going to do a double bunch of
delivery business yeah and I put a in
Florida places pizza places hiring
plenty more people to run deliveries
which which I can obviously understand I
don't know so much about Chinese
restaurants right now I think there's a
lot of there's a lot of fear well I'm
married to a Korean man and some of the
things that people say on social media
and in posted there people it's just
ridiculous I mean again that's that's
uninformed uneducated people that it
just scared yeah another guy in my town
who runs a little barbecue place he's
selling food and household supplies on
the side because his
his vendors aren't having any problem
his supply chains been just great and so
he's I don't know if he's making a
profit or or selling at a cost but
people are going to him for for staples
what is this is what I believe in it is
if there's an ulterior way to make money
obviously barbecuers is a great pickup
and eat food for sure but let's face it
I mean you go to the stores and not as
bad as you were a week ago but at least
you can still get some stuff if people
can can without gouging obviously I mean
we're doing the same thing in our
distillery boardroom we now make you
sanitize to make more money off
sanitizer and we're giving it away now
think about that we're making more money
than we we do an alcohol at the moment
because people are more scared about
their house so we turn out there selling
over to through making a hand sanitizer
you take your container four to six
ounces every day up to two board rooms
person Lansdale they'll give you the
sanitizer as well as we were feeding the
National Guard with sanitizer
firefighters police departments you know
listen at the end of the day better
adapt and conquer and right now we need
to stay alive I don't even do I didn't
fill iam yeah we're just reading about
your distiller I didn't even know you
had it there in Pennsylvania what do you
usually make so we do vodka we do gin
rum
bourbon scotch and now obviously we're
still making those vodkas and whatnot
but a huge crime but we just hired a
couple more part-time people to do the
sanitizer because obviously
need for it so I mean the National Guard
according the different states fire
departments police departments because
you know they're the frontline folks
don't have it all kind get hold of it so
you know we've kind of done that a lot
of other distillers now we're just
trying to make you better for people
make the time go faster and it's hard to
say that with people not making money
but hopefully as I just said we're the
government changed now and hopefully get
some money into some people's hands so
they can feel like they're in control
again pay some pills have some money in
the pockets because the restaurant
industry unless we
something is all hospitality I should
say that's we do something really
dramatic really fast there is not gonna
be one that's Hotels that's motels that
where anybody's through food and alcohol
yeah I mean that's it's such a low
margin business to begin with and it's
one thing to have a big restaurant group
or maybe you've got a cushion but if
you're a mom-and-pop place but you know
that has ten tables in it somebody's
probably going to have to help you with
your nut after a month or two or three
yeah and that's what I've been doing for
the last you know nine years where you
get on Restaurant Impossible trying to
figure those out now obviously these
numbers gonna skyrocket through the roof
of failures and it's not because of
themselves is because of a virus that
you know nobody was prepared for
unfortunately it's going to take time to
put this even this grand fiscal stimulus
is done it's gonna take time to put
hands in business and money in business
and that's where we need to do it I
truly believe it if the government give
these incentives I know it's more
business administration they've been
working really hard on you know let's
put money to the business if you keep
all your employees for three months and
we loan you money what we'll look at the
other way kind of get rid of it if you
keeping your people employed I mean
that's not being made public yet but you
know with all all the ins and outs of
the government lending but if they put
money to this business is business or
thrive I still think we're personally
with to trillions of dollars down and
what we need to stop a recession but you
know hey listen my hope is that we can
continue to fight this virus get people
back to work get money in their hands
and give them a bright outlook because
right now there's a lot of fears a lot
of scared people out there not knowing
what's real what's not real as much as
we put information out and I appreciate
you doing this as much as we put
information out other information
contradicts what theme put out so you
know it's hard to understand what was
real and what's not
yeah well I do hope that you know we're
doing our best trying to get the truth
out there and about this virus and I do
hope as far as the restaurants go that
we don't see on
other side a bunch of empty storefronts
depressing communities further once were
past this one more thing you're a big
Fitness guy any advice on how maybe
sedentary people who are now even more
sedentary can use this time to their
advantage maybe in better shape well
listen the beautiful thing about TV is
you can get everything on it now there
are fitness workouts on TV there there
are online workouts but people doing
free workouts I use with my wife at home
we do some some working out I'm doing
workout videos and cooking videos in
fact the next cover lady's gonna do one
you know I ripped my shoulder out in
November last year so I've been
rehabilitated so I'm gonna show folks
how to do you know some work out while
you're rehabilitating if you're not used
to fitness
if you're bored at home what do we did a
big cooking thing worldwide on Instagram
which was amazing because we had people
from Pakistan and Italy from Germany
just all over the globe in America and
it is these times that just need a
little uplift now we've just sent Big
Crunch Bars to Fort Bliss for all the
troops that are there are quarantined
there we're doing videos for the USO for
for Italy right now for quarantined
servicemen and women over there it's up
everywhere the whole world is going
through the same thing so you know
whatever you can do if you got a couple
of fake bean cans or or cannellini bean
cans you do push-ups sit-ups I just
posted yesterday on my Twitter a workout
I did six years ago in a hotel room so
there's lots you can be doing and of
course you can still walk outside just
keeping away from people the social
distancing not everyday but to break
that monotony there's lots of things we
can be doing but the biggest thing I
want to say Chris is we ought to be nice
to each other
gonna help each other this is everybody
in the same boat well I'm on your side
here buddy Robert Irvine Food Network
host is a chef founder the Robert Irvine
foundation Robert thanks a lot for
checking in I appreciate again
I appreciate what you do and put now
information good information to a lot of
people really fast catch you on the
other side but all right thank you Oh
g'day thanks
[Music]
download Perino and steyr walls I don't
tell you what I woke up at 6:30
you know usually good about 5:30 so I
feel like I'm quite behind I'm a wreck
you are definitely not at part of the 11
PMC no I want to be I aspire to be but I
just can't hey subscribe and listen now
I going to a Fox News podcast calm rate
and review the Fox News rundown on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen it's
time for your fox news commentary what's
on your mind my husband dr. Asghar
Hussein is an orthopedic surgeon that
means he fixes broken bones he
specializes in shoulder elbow and knee
injuries he not only takes care of
professional athletes but also children
who fall off their bunk beds older
people who fall down and the usual
weekend warriors for my husband and most
orthopedic surgeons the majority 90% of
my husband's case the majority of the
cases he performs the surgeries are
elective with the urgency of this corona
virus pandemic hospitals of recently
asked surgeons to stop doing all
elective surgeries there are two reasons
for that one there aren't enough
supplies like masks and gloves to go
around and two there are no beds if a
patient operated on needs one all are
taken and are running out fast for
patients infected with the corona virus
my husband had to phone the majority of
his patients last week and tell them he
could not operate on them for injuries
such as torn rotator cuffs meniscus and
ACLs most of the patients were
understanding but some who are in pain
are worried about waiting 30 days or
more for surgery my husband is currently
considered a second line physician in
this battle against coronavirus the
first or front line are the doctors and
nurses who come into contact with
coronavirus patients daily but to show
you just how fast this virus is
spreading my husband was asked last week
not if but when according to the
hospital some of the front line either
become infected or need to be
quarantined if he would be willing to
come up to the front line my husband
said yes of course he not only took an
oath but he and other doctors in the
medical community believe this is a
societal issue and they
a responsibility to help stop the spread
of this virus and to care for those who
are suffering and who might eventually
die from it when my husband told me this
of course I was concerned not only for
him but for my children he thinks it
could happen in the next two or three
weeks we discussed him living at the
hospital or one of the hotels near the
hospital that have been provided for
healthcare workers so they can remain
away from their families while working
on the front line I asked my husband how
he feels about this virus and the
situation we are in and he said one of
the most frustrating things for medical
personnel is not only how fast this
virus spreads but also how long it lives
on surfaces outside the body and once
inside the body how it attacks the cells
he also shared with me recently an email
from a doctor in Italy the man sounded
so despondent it was heartbreaking
coronavirus is not just a medical issue
for the medical community it's also a
financial one people aren't paying their
co-pays or deductibles hospitals and
doctors offices aren't required to
collect them during this time if
patients can't pay 90% of surgeries
aren't being performed many hospitals
doctors nurses EMTs techs and other
medical personnel are working with
reduced or even no pay many are
volunteering their time like the
healthcare professionals who've come out
of retirement to assist with this burden
that the virus is currently placed on
our healthcare system and its workers
that means these people are working
tirelessly risking their lives for all
of us daily and some of them aren't even
getting paid they fear that they will
lose their savings their retirement or
even their homes in the process when I
hear about a bailout for the airline
industry I get it but where is the
bailout for the health care industry for
health care workers looking at China and
South Korea we know that someday we will
all be on the other side of this virus
when that happens I hope all of you
remember the true heroes in this fight
against kovat 19 it's not politicians
but scientists
nurses volunteers techs paramedics EMTs
physician's assistants and doctors like
my husband who made that all possible I
hope you will never forget that America
this doctor's wife never will
i'm leslie marshall you've been
listening to the fox news rundown and
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at fox news podcasts calm and
for up-to-the-minute news go to Fox
news.com fox news click the subscribe
button to get more of the news and
opinion you trust and click the FoxNews
rundown playlist for the latest episodes